[Música]
Olá, boa noite. Prazer falar com vocês
novamente para mais uma live dos
apoiadores
da comunidade fechada.
Temos quatro perguntas interessantes e
em seguida eu vou discutir mais uns
artigos que ficou da semana passada.
Primeira pergunta que eu recebi
foi a respeito da apolipoproteína A.
e LDL também.
Ah, desculpa essa pergunta que foi da
semana passada. Deixa eu abrir o arquivo
correto aqui.
A pergunta é sobre o tratamento da
apolipoproteína a aumentada. atuar o
acho que a pessoa fez uma confusão aqui.
Deve ser LPA que ela quis dizer. É bem
parecido, né?
Então, qual o tratamento para LP
aumentado? LDL também está aumentado.
Então, dentro da medicina ortodoxa não
tem um tratamento muito eficiente de
fácil acesso para controle da LPA.
A lipo proteína um é outra coisa, é a
parte proteica do HDL colesterol. Isso
daí é algo que você quer que fique alto?
Sim.
Então para o controle da LPA que não
temos drogas disponíveis no dia a dia e
com facilidade para reduzir isso, tem
uns protocolos da medicina funcional.
Nesse protocolo principal é a terapia
com neiacina ou com exenicotinato
deitol. Obrigado, Eliseu, pelo feedback.
Quais são os pró do exicotinato de
inozitol? Ele é uma molécula de inozitol
ligado a seis moléculas de nicotinato e
não tem aquele problema habitual de dar
o flush, de dar o vermelhão no rosto.
Então tem a liberação controlada. Isso
impede o flush, que são os efeitos
vasomotores.
Então isso permite uma aderência
terapêutica devido ao melhor perfil de
toabilidade
e tem uma eficácia de 20 a 30% na
redução do LPA. E a gente vai aumentando
a dose aos poucos. A dose que seria
plena, que tem os melhores efeitos é 3 g
ao dia dexenicotinato dinositolp
dividido em 1 g três vezes ao dia. E
para quem não tem condições de pagar o
exameninato inozitol, porque nessa dose
de 3 g ao dia é um pouco puxado, você
pode usar ncina convencional, que é bem
barata,
tem literatura robusta também de
eficácia contra o LPA.
E tem que ficar aumentando a dose aos
poucos porque dá muito flush, tá? Então
tem que fazer essa titulação. O flush
seria como se fosse uma reação alérgica,
fica a pele fica vermelha e coçando, né?
E é uma sensação bem desagradável.
E nesse terapia com a niacina ou com
exanicotinato em doses elevadas, é
importante fazer o monitoramento da
função hepática, apesar que na prática a
gente não vê problemas na alteração
dessa função.
O tratamento para o NPA aumentado é os
usos de tocotrienóis que são da família
da vitamina E, né? os tocenóis que cuja
fonte mais utilizada aí é urucum, né?
Que no inglês ele chama de anato.
Tem também pode ser extraída do arroz,
né? Mas a melhor fonte é o anato ou
urucum.
Então os tocotrenóis têm uma atividade
antioxidante superior ao alfatocoferol,
tem uma ação na modulação do colesterol,
protege quanto a peroxidação lipídica do
LDL, portanto tem um potencial
antiflamatório interessante
e pode ajudar nesse protocolo de baixar
o LPA junto com a neacina ou exoninato
dinositó.
Aí tem também a coenzima Q10 e a
berberina.
A berberina nós sabemos que aumenta o
HDL colesterol e abaixam também os
triglicérides. E a coenzima que é 10 tem
uma proteção antioxidante mitocondrial.
Então esses dois agentes juntos também
entram nesse protocolo para baixar o
LPA.
Existe também um complexo B metilado com
B2 e B6, metilfolato e metilfobalamina
e vão atuar como cofatores aí para
reduzir a homocisteína e também para
melhorar os nichos de gluta redutase.
Então quando a gente reduz aossistema, a
gente ajuda também a controlar a LPA e
reduz o risco cardiovascular.
Além disso, a gente usa vitamina C em
altas doses, lisina em altas doses e
prolina também. Então tem essa situação
nesse protocolo,
porque a lisina compete com LPA no sítio
de ligação na parede arterial. Então
isso ajuda a evitar o efeito oxidativo
do LPA. A prolina é um precursor do
colágeno e fortalece a matriz
extracelular.
Então eles também ajudam nesse protocolo
de redução do LPA.
Existe também uso do NAC, da arginina e
da elicarnitina,
porque a argenina ela é precursora do
óxido nítrico, ajuda na função
endotelial e a carnitina faz a
otimização do metabolismo lipídico
mitocondrial, aumenta
a quebra do lipídio na mitocôndria,
aumenta,
né, a ação oxidativa na mitocôndria, de
maneira que isso sobra menos gordura
para entupir as artérias.
Também utilizamos o ômega-3 e linhaça
em doses mais altas devido à modulação
das lipoproteínas
aterogênicas e melhora da função
endotelial.
Então é um protocolo bem complexo. A
gente usa exanicotinato deitol oniacina
junto com tocotrienois, junto com com
enzema que é 10, junto com berberina em
complexo B, aminoácido que eu mencionei
a vitamina C mais ômega-3 linhaça.
Por que que tem que tomar tanta coisa ao
mesmo tempo? Porque não tem nenhum
desses agentes isoladamente que seja
muito eficiente, né? Desses daí é o
exctinato de noosol, que é mais
importante ainda para baixar o NPA.
Existe também, tá? uma droga que está
começando a ser desenvolvida
para o controle do RPA,
mas ela é ainda muito muito cara, né?
Então, não recomendo o uso
e ela faz parte de uma classe
nova aí de medicamentos,
que são os inibidores do PC
SK9.
PC9
também reduz em torno de 20 a 30% a LPA,
que é o mesmo efeito do excontinatus
minositol.
Então tem um custo muito alto, tem que
ser administrado debaixo da pele
subcutânea
e o efeito sobre LPA é secundário. Em
estudos tem os óleo nuúcucleotídeos
antiscens,
que reduziria
o LP muito. Aí nesse caso seria acima de
90%.
porém está em fase experimental, não foi
liberado ainda para a compra e o
segurança e a segurança em longo prazo
não foi bem estabelecida ainda.
Bem, a próxima pergunta,
Dr. Alan viu o carro elétrico com bons
olhos e que representa um avanço, mas o
texto a seguir, se for verdadeiro,
talvez me faça mudar de ideia. O que
você acha disso? Bem, então o texto eu
não vou falar aqui, mas
as informações verificadas é que o
campos eletromagnéticos
dos carros elétricos realmente são
intensos, são de baixa frequência,
especialmente durante a aceleração e a
frenagem regenerativa e o carregamento.
Então, os estudos mostram níveis de de
até 3,9
microteslas
em carros híbridos,
especificamente
entre os bancos dianteiros e até 30
microtesla próximo a equipamentos
elétricos internos. Então, a exposição a
esses campos é maior no bloco traseiro e
na Sualho, onde tem uma maior
proximidade com o motor e as baterias.
Então, em 2002, a IAR classificou os
campos magnéticos desses carros como
possivelmente carcinogênicos, que seria
o grupo 2B.
Então essa classificação indica uma
evidência limitada
que não constitui uma prova causal
definitiva. Então tem muitas substâncias
comuns que estão nessa categoria,
inclusive vegetais em vegetais em
conserva.
Em relação ao enjoo de movimento, é
verdadeiro que os carros elétricos podem
causar mais enjoo de movimento que os
carros convencionais e a causa principal
é o conflito sensorial devido à operação
silenciosa e suave.
E nesse caso não teria a ver com os
campos eletromagnéticos.
E o mecanismo desse enjoo de movimento
seria pela falta de vibração e ruído do
motor que impediria que o cérebro
antecipasse movimentos e causando uma
discordância entre o sistema visual e o
sistema do ouvido interno vestibular.
Então, existe uma discussão ainda na
literatura, não é ainda confirmado.
A principal discussão aí é se existe
mesmo essa hipersensibilidade
eletromagnética. A maioria dos médicos
da medicina funcional integrativa
acredita que isso exista,
mas a OMS não reconhece isso ainda como
diagnóstico médico.
Parece que tem estudos duplos cegos que
mostram que pessoas que alegam ter essa
hipersensibilidade magnética
não conseguiriam detectar a presença de
campos eletromagnéticos.
Então eles são considerados por boa
parte aí dos mestres como
psicossomáticos ou efeito nocebo.
Mas isso aqui altamente, já atendi
alguns pacientes que alegam isso daqui,
mas de qualquer maneira é cada vez mais
difícil uma pessoa dessa conviver em
sociedade, né? Porque a radiação
eletromagnética só aumenta cada dia. Eu
acho que a única solução seria essa
pessoa morar num lugar muito remoto,
muito isolado,
uma cabana no meio lá do Alasca para
poder ficar longe dos campos
eletromagnéticos.
Existe alegações também sobre alterações
neurológicas com contato com a radiação
eletromagnética dos carros.
e também de redução da melatonina e de
um risco autoimune. Porém, isso tá sendo
investigado ainda, ainda é considerado
de evidência limitada.
Então, não é possível ainda concluir que
os carros elétricos sejam realmente
fontes desses problemas aí de alterações
neurológicas.
Segundo consta, os níveis medidos nos
carros elétricos estão bem abaixo dos
limites de segurança estabelecidos
internacionalmente.
Então,
sejamos conservadores e práticos, né?
No ponto de vista da medicina funcional
integrativa, é prudente sem aplicar o
princípio de precaução.
Embora os níveis de exposição estejam
aparentemente dentro dos limites
regulamentares,
é importante tomar alguns cuidados. Por
exemplo, limitar o tempo desnecessário
dentro do veículo quando o sistema
elétrico tiver ativo. Nem comprar o
carro elétrico, né? Se você tem essas
preocupações com a exposição
eletromagnética, então é melhor usar um
carro convencional, nem usar um carro
híbrido.
Mas se você fizer a questão do carro
elétrico, você pode considerar também
modelos que têm blindagem
eletromagnética.
Para gestantes e crianças pode ser
prudente preferir os bancos dianteiros
porque tem menos exposição
e monitorar sintomas e considerar
alternativas se houver desconforto
persistente.
Então, o enjoo de movimento em carros
elétricos, ele é real, mas sem solução.
Tem estudos japoneses que mostram que um
tom de 100 Hz por 1 minuto antes da
viagem pode reduzir significativamente
os sintomas.
E tem um a situação que os fabricantes
estão desenvolvendo sinais visuais e
sonoros para ajudar o cérebro a
antecipar os movimentos.
Próxima pergunta é sobre útero
artificial. Quais seriam os impactos
emocionais
no feto e também com relação à saúde?
Isso vai ser muito difícil de responder,
porque isso é uma coisa teórica ainda.
Até dei uma olhada
no material que foi colocado no grupo
sobre isso, mas isso tá sendo ainda
investigado na China. Isso é uma coisa
que eles vão realmente implementar a
partir do ano que vem. tem muitas
dúvidas de fato se vai ser viável essa
gravidez extra útero e úteroartificial.
Então, qualquer coisa que eu falar aqui
vai ser especulação pura e simples, né?
É real, né? Eu dei uma verificada nesse
projeto porque parecia ficção
científica, mas existe mesmo esse
projeto do robô gestacional chinês. Ele
tá sendo desenvolvido pela KA
Technology. Okaia Caiua Okaiva e é
liderada pelo Dr. Jang Kifeng. Ele tem
PhD pela Universidade Tecnológica de
Naniang, né, que é na
na Malásia ali na na região lá de
Singapura.
O projeto foi apresentado na conferência
mundial de robótica em 2025 em Pequim e
o protótipo vai ser lançado ano que vem
ao custo de 14.000 que dá 100.000 on
preços assim
comparado com Estados Unidos é
baratíssimo, né? Então, o sistema
proposto, ele é baseado numa tecnologia
de útero artificial com líquido
aminiótico sintético e um fornecimento
de nutrientes via tubo conectado ao
cordão umbilical.
Então, esse pesquisador Zang, ele afirma
que a tecnologia demonstrou maturidade
em laboratório com modelos animais. Ele
referenciou estudos como Biobeg do
Hospital Infantil da Filadélfia, que foi
nos Estados Unidos, que manteve
cordeiros prematuros vivos por semanas.
Então isso aqui eu acho que não vai ser
viável a curto prazo. Eles vão tentar
fazer isso ano que vem, mas vai ser um
experimento, né? Eu acho vai ser muito
difícil vocês conseguirem fazer uma
gravidez do começo ao fim nesse sistema
aí de útero artificial. Provavelmente o
que vai ser viável vai ser pegar um bebê
já semiformado e passar para um útero
artificial, que não seria muito prático
no mundo real, porque aí se a o objetivo
seria substituir o útero normal, né,
biológico pelo artificial, isso não
seria uma coisa
impactante de só você transferir de um
útero normal para um útero artificial.
Então tem muitas dúvidas sobre esse
projeto, porque existe uma interação
neurobioquímica hormonal muito complexa
entre o feto e a mãe e que eu acho muito
difícil repetir isso daí no útero
artificial.
Vamos falar aqui hipoteticamente de
possíveis preocupações,
tanto neurológicas quanto emocionais de
um sistema artificial desse. A gestação
natural é uma complexa interação
hormonal materno fetal que programa os
sistemas neurológicos fundamentais.
Então, estudos demonstram que o cortisol
materno, quando adequadamente modulado,
ele é essencial pro desenvolvimento do
eixo hipotálabo, hipófise adrenaletal. E
a exposição controlada aos hormônios
maternos durante os períodos críticos da
gestação influenciam influenciam a
mielenização cerebral do bebê.
O desenvolvimento hipocampal, né, que é
uma parte do cérebro relacionado à
memória, é formação de circúos
corticolíbricos.
Então, como é que o útero artificial
conseguiria replicar essas sutis
flutuações hormonais maternas? Não sei,
eu acho muito inviável isso. Seria
necessário variações cicardianas de de
cortisol, de homô estiroidianos e de
neurotransmissores complexos que
atravessariam a barreira placentária?
Como é que eles vão fazer isso se até
hoje a gente não tem um entendimento
muito completo de todos os
neurotransmissores aí que a gente tem em
atividade, né?
Então, essas flutuações seriam
fundamentais para manter a sincronização
dos ritmos biológicos
entre mãe e feto e pro desenvolvimento
de sistema de regulação emocional, tá?
Então, por isso que eu acho que esse
experimento vai ser falho.
Existe também a questão do
comprometimento do vínculo e
desenvolvimento emocional. A literatura
demonstra que o vínculo materno fetal
inicia-se bioquimicamente durante a
gestação através de vários mecanismos e
as variações do batimento cardíaco
materno. Vibrações vocais transmitidas
através do fluido aminiótico e mesmo
variações na química do líquido
aminiótico são baseadas no estado
emocional materno. Como é que você vai
reproduzir isso numa máquina, né? vai
ser bem difícil de acontecer.
Nós sabemos que o sistema nervoso
autonômico fetal ele se desenvolve em
resposta aos padrões de ativação
materna. Então, a ausência desses
estímulos poderia resultar em alterações
permanentes na regulação do sistema
nervoso do feto e predispor a
transtornos de ansiedade, défices
antecionais e dificuldades de regulação
emocional. Boa noite, Maria Helena.
Então, a gestação natural também promove
modificações epigenéticas essenciais
através da exposição a fatores de
transcrição maternos e padrões de
metilação do DNA que são influenciados
pelo ambiente intrauterino. O
ultraartificial não conseguiria
imitar isso ou replicar esses sinais
epigenéticos, né? Seria muito complexo
isso daí.
Isso poderia potencialmente alterar a
expressão gênica em genes críticos para
o neurodesenvolvimento.
Além disso, o metabolismo materno
durante a recetação, ele vai se
adaptando dinamicamente às necessidades
fetais, vai modulando a disponibilidade
de nutrientes específicos em momentos
precisos, né, do desenvolvimento. Então,
o sistema artificial seria muito difícil
de replicar isso,
essa responsidade metabólica dinâmica.
Então, a tecnologia atual dos úteros
artificiais, ele funcionaria mais como
incubadoras neonatais avançadas
para prematuros, como eu comentei,
e não necessariamente como substituto do
começo ao fim da gestação. Então, não
conseguiria dar suporte no
desenvolvimento desde a concepção,
funcionaria mais como uma incubadora
avançada para prematuros extremos.
Então, os estudos com cordeiros que
foram mencionados lá na Filadélphia
demonstraram uma viabilidade apenas para
períodos gestacionais tardios, que é
equivalente a 23 a 28 semanas de
gestação humana. Para uma gestação
completa, seria necessário, então,
replicar não apenas o ambiente físico,
mas também complexos de regulação
hormonal, imunológica e nutricional, que
ainda não são com patrões entendidos ou
compreendidos. pela ciência.
Então eu acho que esse experimento não
vai dar certo.
Temos potenciais riscos com alterações
no desenvolvimento do sistema
imunológico fetal que depende da
exposição controlada antígenos maternos
com o prometimento da programação
metabólica que ocorre naturalmente
durante a gestação e deficiência no
desenvolvimento neurológico que pode não
se manifestar até anos após o
nascimento.
OK? Além disso, tem preocupações éticas
sobre a comoditização da reprodução
humana e o potencial impacto na
estrutura familiar tradicional, né? E
seria mais uma coisa para destruir a
família fora todo o ataque woke que
aconteceu já nos últimos anos aí nesse
sentido.
Então eu acho que realmente esse esse
experimento não vai dar certo, tá? Vamos
ver o que vai acontecer o ano que vem.
Próxima pergunta. Numa live feita alguns
meses, você recomendou usar a regra
2020. Em seguida, você explicou: "A cada
20 minutos, olhando a tela do celular,
ficaram 20 segundos olhando para longe,
a uma distância de pelo menos 6 m. Não
faltou um 20 aí, não. O 20 que faltou é
justamente 6 m, porque o 20 da regra do
inglês é 20 pés.
Como a gente não usa pés aqui no Brasil,
a gente substitui pelos 6 m, tá? É a
equivalência em metros. Então os 320s é
mais aplicado para Estados Unidos e
Inglaterra que usa o sistema não
métrico, né? 20 minutos de intervalo
entre as pausas, 20 segundos de duração
da pausa e 20 pés de distância que a
gente converte para 6 m, tá?
Então, foi isso que você não tinha
entendido. O Eliseu está ao vivo, então
ele deve estar me ouvindo.
Bem, vamos falar agora sobre os artigos,
né? Eu vou conversar com vocês sobre uma
descoberta científica bem recente. Foi
publicado há poucos dias atrás numa das
revistas mais respeitados do mudo e pode
mudar completamente a forma como
tratamos aqueles problemas íntimos que
incomodam as mulheres.
Então vocês todos conhecem, né, casos
até as mulheres aí presentes que t essa
situação das candidias de repetição.
E é muito comum mulheres que tomam
antibióticos aí para qualquer tipo de
infecção, como por exemplo, infecção
urinária ou respiratória, e desenvolve a
vaginose bacteriana logo em seguida.
E muitas vezes essa vaginose é de
difícil tratamento, fica refidivando
mesmo utilizando os antifúng. Então,
pesquisadores descobriram que existe uma
bactéria específica, né, que chama-se
lactobacilos crispatos, que quando está
presente em quantidade suficiente na
vagina, ela blinda o ambiente contra
infecções fúng.
Então esse lactobacus crispatos não é
uma novidade exatamente, mas
essa pesquisa demonstrou que tem papel
aí protetor contra a candidase
e nós descobrimos que 90% das mulheres,
nove em cada 10, não tem quantidade
suficiente da LCRPATOS.
Então a gente precisa atuar para
recuperar essa população.
Então nesse estudo que saiu em agosto de
2025, há poucos dias atrás, os
pesquisadores pegaram três cepas
diferentes da Crispatos, do lactobacus
e criaram o que eles chamam de
simbiótico vaginal.
Sibiótico é quando você junta
probiótico,
que são as bactérias do bem, com
prebiótico, que é a comida dessas
bactérias é a fibra.
Então eles fizeram essa associação para
aumentar a eficiência.
Então eles analisaram por anos o
microbioma vaginal de milhares de
mulheres ao redor do mundo e descobriram
que quando a vagina está saudável, ela
não precisa ter uma diversidade enorme
de bactérias, como é o caso do
intestino. Então ela funcionaria melhor
quando é dominada por uma única espécie
que é justamente o lactobacío crispatos.
Então eles testaram esse simbiótico em
mulheres reais,
não só foi em laboratório. E 90% das
participantes que tinham disbiose
vaginal, que a flora tava bagunçada,
conseguiram estabelecer uma microbiota
saudável em apenas 21 dias.
Sim, é assim que se escreve, Eliseu.
Então, em 21 dias, três semanas, houve
essa melhora enorme aí da disbiose
vaginal, utilizando essa bactéria
crrispat.
Então, o estudo mostrou que esse
simbiótico foi 10 vezes mais eficaz do
que os probióticos orais que a gente
encontra nas famácias.
E quando você toma um probiótico pela
boca, ele tem que passar pelo estômago,
pelo ácido do estômago e muitas vezes
ele não consegue chegar até o final do
intestino.
Então, utilizando esse simbiótico por
via vaginal, os resultados são bem
melhores.
Então descobriram também nessa pesquisa
que o garderela vaginales, aquela
bactéria chatinha, na verdade é um
protozoário, causa vaginose
e também acaba sendo um composição aí
com a Cândida, né, nas vaginosas.
Então, quando você utiliza o crispatos,
nesses casos de gardinera também tem uma
ação significativa na melhora dessa
candidíase, a, desculpa, dessa vaginose,
assim como acontece quando é candidase,
né, quando a infecção vaginal é causada
pela cândida. Então, tanto a candidase
quanto a gardinerela vaginales eh
tiveram um bom resultado utilizando o
errados.
E como é que o Elcrispatus vai atuar
para combater essas vaginoses? Aí
primeiro ele produz o ácido láctico.
Isso mantém o pH vaginal ácido entre 3.8
e 5. Produz também substâncias
antimicrobianas, tipo
uns antibióticos naturais. E terceiro,
ele literalmente ocupa espaço, não
deixando lugar para as bactérias ruins
se instalarem.
E outra coisa interessante também
constatado nesse estudo é que o
microbioma vaginal ele muda ao longo da
vida da mulher, antes da puberdade é
dominado por bactérias anaeróbicas e
durante a idade reprodutiva os
lactobacíos assumem o comando,
principalmente por causa do estrogênio
que vai aumentando e depois da
menopausa, eh, isso vai mudar novamente
porque ela queda pela queda do
estrogênio.
E é por isso que muitas mulheres, né,
com deficiência de estrogênio, começam a
ter mais infecções vaginais, justamente
porque essas bactérias de lactobacilas
vão caindo também.
Então, existe uma empresa que participou
desse estudo e
se chama Sed Health.
Então esse produto deve est disponível
em breve aí para a compra.
Eles testaram várias formas de
administração, comprimido vaginal, cáula
vaginal e cáula oral. Descobriram que o
comprimido vaginal com tecnologia de
liberação prolongada é o mais eficaz.
Ele vai liberando as bactérias e os
nutrientes aos poucos.
Infelizmente, a maioria dos produtos que
estão no mercado hoje em dia não tem as
certas
na quantidade certa com a tecnologia
correta. Então, a gente tem que esperar
mais um tempo aí para liberar isso paraa
venda
que não seja manipulado, né?
E tem um outro detalhe importante que o
estudo revelou. Existe uma classificação
do microbioma vaginal em cinco tipos
diferentes chamados de CST,
tá? que é o community state types. Tem
um tipo um que é dominado pelo
elcrispatos, que é o melhor, é o mais
protetor.
O tipo quatro, que tem maior mais
diversidade bacteriana e poucos
lactobacos, que é o mais problemático.
Então você tem cinco tipos e tem esses
dois tipos aí que são os prevalentes.
tipo um, que é o dominado por el
crrispato, tipo quatro que tem
diversidade bacteriana e poucos
lactobacilos.
E os pesquisadores descobriram que
fatores como estresse, relações sexuais,
menstruação, dieta, uso excessivo de
sabonetes íntimos, duchas vaginais, tudo
isso pode desequilibrar o microbioma
vaginal e é por isso que muitas mulheres
têm infecções recorrentes.
E a disbiose vaginal não só aumenta o
risco de corrimento e coceira, mas
também aumenta o risco de infecções
sexualmente transmissíveis. Pode causar
problemas na gravidez com o parto
prematuro, diminui a taxa de sucesso de
fertilização em vitro. Então é um
problema muito mais sério do que a gente
imagina.
E existem já estudos para transplante de
microbioma
vaginal, bem interessante, tipo que já
acontece para microbiota fecal,
então será possível em breve pegar a
microbiota vaginal saudável de uma
mulher e transplantar para outra e sofre
com infecções recorrentes.
Então, encerrando a conversa sobre esse
artigo, então esse estudo representa uma
mudança de paradigma no tratamento de
problemas vaginais. Estamos saindo da
era do mata tudo com antibiótico e
antifúng
para a era do vamos fortalecer as
defesas naturais do nosso organismo.
Então isso é o quê? É o fortalecimento
da medicina personalizada, na medicina
funcional. Então estamos tendo avanços.
E se você é uma mulher que sofre com
infecções vaginais recorrentes ou
conhece alguém na situação, saiba que a
ciência está trabalhando duro para
encontrar soluções melhores.
Bem, temos aqui
o que é melatonina bifásica.
Bifásica seria que tem metade liberação
lenta e metade liberação rápida. Ó,
Eliseu,
tá? Seria isso.
O quebra-pedra, ele tem um efeito
diurético, sim, ele pode aumentar a
frequência que a pessoa urina.
Boa noite, Alice Vogel.
Eu
não entendi a pergunta. É possível
conseguir uma lista de F manipulação
cadastrada, essa de farmácia de
manipulação, né, no Anfarmag?
Eu acho que você consegue obter isso
fazendo uma busca no Google, né? Eu não
nunca fiz essa busca não.
Não, não conheço essa informação não,
Eliseu. Mas vamos ao último artigo aqui
pra gente encerrar a nossa conversa de
hoje.
Existe um conceito interessante de
resistoma intestinal.
É um estudo fascinante que saiu agora em
agosto de 2025 também que liga
diretamente o que a gente coloca no
prato com uma questão super séria de
saúde pública. Sabe aquela história de
que você é o que você come?
Então parece que isso vai muito além do
que a gente imaginava.
Imaginem só que dentro do nosso
intestino vivem trilhões de bactérias. É
uma verdadeira metrópole microscópica. E
essas bactérias, elas carregam um
arsenal de genes que elas tornam
resistentes a antibióticos.
É como se elas tivessem um manual de
sobrevivência genético que elas
transferem a resistência de uma para as
outras.
E os cientistas chamam isso de resistoma
intestinal.
A ideia é simples, é o conjunto de todos
os genes de resistência que existem no
nosso intestino.
Então, o estudo que eu tô referenciando,
ele foi publicado no NPJ, Biofilms and
Microbiomes.
E os pesquisadores descobriram que
quando a gente segue uma dieta rica em
gordura artificial e pobre em fibra,
tipo aquela dieta do brasileiro moderno,
cheia de ultraprocessado, fast food,
fritura, o resistoma intestinal
literalmente aumenta. Olha que curioso.
É como se a gente tivesse turbinando as
bactérias do intestino, dando superperes
para elas resistirem aos antibióticos.
Olha que coisa interessante.
Pensa comigo. Você tá ali comendo aquele
hambúrguer suculento, batata frita,
crocante, tomando refrigerante. Mas
enquanto você tá curtindo essa junk
food, lá no seu intestino está rolando
uma verdadeira revolução bacteriana. as
bactérias que adoram gordura começam a
proliferar, enquanto aquelas que
dependem de fibra vão minguando.
Lembrando que eu tô falando de gorduras
artificiais, tá? E o pior, as que
crescem nesse ambiente muduroso são
justamente as que carregam mais genes de
resistência aos antibióticos.
Para imaginem que o seu intestino é como
um condomínio quando você come muita
fibra, aquelas verduras, legumes, frutas
leguminosas, né, os feijões do dia a
dia, você tá traindo moradores do bem
pro condomínio.
Então são bactérias que produzem
substâncias defamatórias, que ajudam na
digestão, que mantém a ordem do local.
Mas quando você corta as fibras e
aumenta a gordura ruim, é como se você
estivesse expulsando os moradores do bem
e abrindo as portas pros baderneiros.
E esses baderneiros,
além de fazerem bagunça, ainda são
resistentes quando você tenta tirar os
dear com os antibióticos.
Então, estudo em questão usou uma
técnica chamada metagenômica,
que permite aos cientistas lerem todo o
DNA presente no intestino, não só das
nossas células, mas de todas as
bactérias que moram ali. Então, é como
fazer um senso completo da população
bacteriana e ainda descobrir que
habilidades cada uma tem e o que eles
encontraram foi assustador. Quanto mais
gordura e menos fibra na dieta, maior a
quantidade de genes que conferem
resistência a múltiplos antibióticos.
Então, o que que significa isso na
prática? Vou dar um exemplo. Imagina que
daqui alguns anos você precise tomar um
antibiótico para tratar uma infecção. Se
seu intestino tá cheio dessas bactérias
resistentes, elas podem passar esse gene
de resistência paraas bactérias que
estão te causando a infecção. Olha só
que coisa.
É como se elas ensinassem o truque da
sobrevivência umas paraas outras. Então,
os antibióticos não vão funcionar de
maneira adequada e aquela infecção
simples pode virar um problemão.
A boa notícia é que isso é reversível.
Estudos recentes mostram que quando a
gente muda o padrão alimentar, incluindo
mais fibras, e não precisa ser nada
mirabulante, é fibras comuns, tá? Mais
feijão, lentilha, grão de bico, aveia.
fruta com casca, verduras, em poucas
semanas já dá para ver mudanças
positivas no resistoma. É como se a
gente fizesse uma reforma no condomínio
intestinal, trazendo de forma os
moradores, trazendo de volta os
moradores do bem. Então, dado
interessante que eu encontrei
pesquisando sobre isso, pessoas que
consomem pelo menos 25 a 40 g de fibra
por dia tem um resistoma intestinal
significativamente menor do que aquelas
que mal chegam a 15 g.
E a maioria dos brasileiros não chegam a
15 g.
E tem mais, as fibras solúveis, aquelas
que encontramos na aveia, nas maçãs, nas
periras, elas viram alimento para
bactérias boas e essas bactérias
fermentam as fibras e produzem
substâncias chamado ácido grasso cadeia
curta, né, que é o botirato
principalmente.
Eh,
pense nesse ácido gráxico cadeia culta
como se fosse vitaminas produzidas pelas
próprias bactérias. Então, esses
compostos reduzem a inflamação, melhoram
a barreira intestinal e ainda dificulta
o crescimento das bactérias resistentes.
Já as gorduras, principalmente as trans
dos alimentos ultraprocessados,
das frituras dos salgadinhos, elas
aumentam a penabilidade intestinal. É
como se abrissem buracos na parede do
intestino. Isso permite que toxinas
bacterianas, como as lipopolissacarídeos
escapem paraa corrente sanguínea,
causando uma inflamação de baixo grau no
corpo todo e favorecendo o crescimento
de bactérias existentes e aumentando o
risco de diabetes, doenças cardíacas e
até alguns tipos de câncer.
O mais importante é que esse estudo não
é isolado. Pesquisadores do mundo todo
estão encontrando resultados similares
na China. Um estudo com crianças obesas
mostrou que uma dieta rica em grãos
integrais e prebióticos não só ajudou na
perda de peso, como reduziu o resistoma
intestinal em quase 70%.
Bastante coisa, né?
E não para por aí. Comparando com
populações diferentes, os cientistas
descobriram que crianças africanas que
vivem em áreas rurais e comem uma dieta
tradicional, fica em fibras e pobre em
gordura, tem um resistoma muito menor do
que crianças italianas e seguem a dieta
ocidental típica. Então é a prova de que
nossos nossos hábitos alimentares
modernos estão criando um problema sério
de saúde pública.
Então pensem assim, cada escolha
alimentar que você faz é um voto. Você
tá votando a favor das bactérias do bem
ou das bactérias resistentes. Então é
importante você votar mais a favor das
bactérias do bem, né?
E não precisa ser radical. Comecemos aos
poucos, incluindo uma fruta no café da
manhã, trocando o arroz branco pelo
integral algumas vezes na semana,
comendo mais feijão,
mais leguminosas, salada colorida,
folhas, tomate, cenoura, essas mudanças,
mesmo que pequenas, contam.
Então está surgindo um conceito de
stewardship antimicrobiano metabólico,
né? um termo aí chique que os cientistas
estão utilizando, que nada mais que a
gente cuidar do nosso arsenal de
antibióticos através da alimentação.
Então é uma maneira barata e preventiva
de evitar existência bacteriana que está
totalmente sob o nosso controle,
que não depende de desenvolvimento de
antibióticos muito caros aí para passar
por cima das resistências bacterianas.
Então, cada vez mais tá claro que nossa
alimentação tem um impacto profundo, não
só no nosso peso ou na energia, mas
também na nossa capacidade de responder
as infecções no futuro. Cada vez que
escolhemos alimentos ricos em fibra e
reduzim os ultraprocessados
e os ricos em gorduras ruins, estamos
fazendo investimento nossa saúde a longo
prazo. Estamos literalmente desarmando
as bombas relógios bacterianas que podem
explodir quanto mais precisarmos de que
os antibióticos funcionem.
Beleza? Então, esse tudo é bem bem
interessante.
Tem um último estudo aqui, mas eu vou
deixar paraa semana que vem.
Tiver as perguntas aqui,
comer 40 g de proteína antidumínio não
atrapalha digestão?
40 g não. Agora se você comer muita
comida vai atrapalhar a digestão, sim.
Tá mais 40 g não chega a ser o
suficiente para atrapalhar, não.
Sim. É reconhecido que comer eh proteína
antes de dormir pode ajudar no
crescimento do músculo se você fizer
treinos suficientes e dormir o
suficiente. Não adianta vai comer 40 g
de proteína na hora de dormir se você
não tá fazendo o resto.
Para quem não toma suplemento magnésio,
consumir todo dia dois abacates, mas a
porção de espinaf dá uma quantidade de
magnésio suficiente. Sim.
Pessoas bariátricas gastam mais B12 do
que pessoas não bariátricas no mesmo
período de tempo?
Não, não é questão de gastar, é a
absorção que é bem prejudicada nos
bariátricos.
Não sei dizer, não conheço estudos
mostrando isso.
Bem, pessoal, obrigado aí pela
participação de vocês. Semana que vem
nós voltamos nos conversar. Até até
mais.